oh so it's official now oh my god after
several months of dating pete davidson
referred to kim kardashian west as his
girlfriend for the first time during an
interview the saturday night live star
was speaking out about his upcoming
super bowl commercial when he opened up
about his personal life and his
experiences in the spotlight saying
quote i don't have an instagram or
twitter or any of that stuff so most of
my daily life is getting into cars and
showing up to set if i'm off i just
either hang out with my friends or chill
with my girlfriend inside so i don't do
much i'm happy to be here pete and kim
sparked romance rumors in october
shortly after she made her snl hosting
debut
after a number of pda-packed dinner
dates that relationship was confirmed
the following month how you going to
bring me to snl
and kiss the dude you dating right in
front of me pete calling kim his
girlfriend comes amid the reality star's
increasingly contentious divorce from
estranged husband kanye west
who during an interview last month
reacted to how kim kissed the comedian
on snl and everybody's like oh that's
that's cool
kim filed for divorce from the rapper in
february of last year fast forward to
2022 and the two are publicly feuding on
social media in a now deleted post kaye
called kim out for allowing their
eight-year-old daughter north to be on
tick-tock quote against his will of
course kim and north share a joint
account and often post videos together
like this
kim responded to yates claims with a
lengthy statement on her instagram story
defending north using the app with
parental supervision and writing in part
quote divorce is difficult enough on our
children and kanye's obsession with
trying to control and manipulate our
situation so negatively and publicly
it's only causing further pain for all
according to an et source kanye choosing
to lash out on social media is quote his
way of fighting to get his family back
the source says kanye still has hope
that he and kim will get back together
everything he has been doing has been
coming from a place of feeling deeply
hurt and detached adding quote all kaye
cares about is that his family is good
taken care of and happy he has been
showing it in the wrong way but that's
all that matters to him meanwhile pete
says he isn't fazed by all the media
scrutiny and intense fan interest that
has come with his and kim's relationship
noting that it hasn't had much of an
impact on his actual day-to-day life